- And then to top this
all off, my bar mitzvah.
I was Jewish.
Am Jewish.
- Oh, I was like, were you?
Are you now or?
- Yes.
- Look at you!
- Oh, there I am!
- You're so cute.
- I was so fat.
- Well, once again, we went opposite.
I'm now fatter.
We went opposite.
What was your bar mitzvah like?
- So, I didn't really care about
the religious part so much,
but I really cared about the party.
I was obsessed with the party,
and, you know, every bar mitzvah
party had this big theme.
And so the theme of mine,
because I couldn't decide,
was Broadway meets pop music.
Which, one gay man
laughed, in this audience.
Which is an odd theme.
What does that even mean?
There was a like a
life-sized cutout of Madonna
on one side of the DJ booth.
There are tears in your eyes right now.
And on the other side of the DJ booth,
and this is not an exaggeration,
was a life-sized cutout of
The Phantom of the Opera.
- That was the first musical I ever saw.
- Which I was obsessed with at the time.
And all the kid's tables were named
after pop stars that I loved at the time.
I sat at the Madonna table.
There was a George Michael table.
Aerosmith for the straight boys.
And then all the adult tables
were named after Broadway shows.
- It was rock and roll.
They might have been open.
You never know.
- Exactly.
And that was my crazy childhood.